[Music]
Oh in body black-market new submitted by
turn the AC on the FBI found bodies sewn
together like Frankenstein at a body
donation facility whoa body donation
facility and why are they doing that
so this facility it's part of this crazy
like black market it's not necessarily
black market even though we titled it
that it's like a legal thing where
people can sign up to these research
centers to donate their body to science
right and then they offer to cremate you
for free we're talking about
specifically this Arizona based
biological resource center and that's
that's called the be our seat and they
are saying that they targeted a lot of
low-income people because they were
tanta for the funeral exactly the cowboy
funeral they're just trying to get as
much body parts as they can and what
they were not being clear about is the
fact that they profit off of these
bodies instead of you thinking like you
know if I'm dying I want to gorshani
but instead they're making money off of
your body do they make money off of this
sell it on the black market sell it so
people can eat it so you can do all kind
of [ __ ] they can take your finger and
turn into a pencil sharpener chip for
some rich dude who has like a rhino head
on his wall they haven't used the term
black market is just that they are they
are selling these body parts to other
like medical training programs or
research facility subs that's illegal
all right that's science-based
exactly so that they're not disclosing
it to the people but the part that so
they're making profit cuz it's the
people go in with the thinking that it's
gonna be nonprofit or used for science
and also one of these cases too they
were saying that there was this little
box that if you check that box and that
means you are consenting for your body
to be used for military experiments and
there were these two cases where these
men did not want their bodies to be used
and so they specifically did not check
that box but then once they had died
they didn't give a [ __ ] people like
they're dead anyway yeah BRC bum-rush
the widows and pretty much like Wow
pretty much
Vince them to do that and then they
ended up being shipped to the military
places do you think they sell bodies by
the roll I could tell you how they sell
it to my sheet that's not thinking
because if you take skin maybe you could
stretch it and you can cut into two
pieces and then you make double money
what if they have implants so oh that
boobie implants all kinds more expensive
than the arm yeah good legit so I can
tell you the priceless Oh tell me yeah I
think a butcher shop so a whole body
with no shoulders or head goes for a two
thousand nine hundred so that's just
like a torso a lot of money well let's
do really that's pretty neat yeah that's
a lot a torso with a head is 2,400 when
you throw that head in it's cheaper well
I'm assuming it's without I want the
head though me too I don't know a whole
spine goes for nine hundred and fifty
dollars just the spine a whole leg goes
for $1100 a whole foot is 450 Amy is 375
are these prices negotiable and a pelvis
is $400 they have a price list it's just
like you go there and you shop for you I
wonder what they use it for ken can you
use that to like oh I need a new knee
research for this what's all research
they do have like detailed transactions
and where they go and like whose body
part went where and how much it costs
and all this stuff and so they keep
records of that stuff yeah they do keep
records that have been on everything
because they have been saying like after
all this investigation that there's just
still some body parts there like the
military experiment one makes me think
Wolverine oh did you know that in China
they just did a human animal hybrid with
a chimpanzee and a human I heard about
that and it was born oh I'm sorry it was
it was like developed they did it
successfully so I'm saying and then they
aborted it yeah but like pretty [ __ ]
crazy that is gonna happen for real it's
a monkey with Asian eyes yeah it's a
Chinese monkey that's crazy they did it
on purpose in China obviously because of
all the international issues with that
show where can you find these body parts
as their webs you look for Chinese
monkey
so the content on my own
the agents discovered 10 tons of frozen
human remains which were about 1555
total body parts that included 281 heads
241 shoulders 337 legs and 97 spines and
so there's a lot of people that die
every year though I would hate to be the
head counter if I was part of the team
I'd rather count like a spine but also
you know what's crazy - after the
embassy I don't look at the face they
found that people working here had like
little to no training and they were
handling these body parts so it was just
like in a very unprofessional manner
that they handled these human remains
like chuck chuck in a head yeah they
even use like Home Depot
it's like saws and [ __ ] like what they
were gonna say like day laborers you
[ __ ] caught with a truck at Home
Depot they're like hey let me go the
council Cabezas okay you got a line of
Hector's just [ __ ] throwing heads and
[ __ ] like is it disrespectful to use
Home Depot
no it's just professional like there's
no like actual surgery oh yeah that's
not surgical a surgical saw versus like
a zebra though get like a weed whacker
yeah what's happening here okay the
problem with that is the fact that they
can't actually get into disinfecting it
and so they're transferring diseases to
other body parts when they're shipping
them out to their clients are dominating
they're contaminating these body parts
that's another like I wonder how to keep
them fresh they had to freeze them so
they freeze them and then they had to
cut it like while it's frozen like it's
a butcher shop oh I don't know to that
extent oh-de-boy have to defrost in the
microwave before they start cutting it
so after the agents raided this place
like a health hazard
they took 142 bags and bodies that had
parts from at least 36 different people
and they're saying that the agent
involved in this investigation like some
of them you ain't got PTSD because the
way that they had to just transfer these
human remains
yeah the freezers in like where there
facilities like some of the bags like it
was like all sloshy and like there was
like leaking bags where it even stains
sent one of the agents decomposing
already yeah horror movie dude exactly
and they're saying that they found body
parts like sewn up together like a
Frankenstein my gosh yeah it's insane
like twisted things happening
Jeff can I ask you a question what let's
say you're part of this team and then
like you turn in a bag full of body
parts right and then dick and balls fell
on the ground
how would you pick that up what do you
mean like how would you pick it up and
sell it just fell down like you're like
oh [ __ ] you felt a lot of bad dick and
balls yeah it's it's ticking balls out
of the bag
how would you think like the balls are
here the dick is there we've grabbed it
like that she's using your bare hands
could you grab it from the balls yeah
would obviously be having gloves what do
some people grab by the shaft no I would
combine the balls like this about here
that's pretty good yeah probably throw
it at someone just because it's there
but you're an agent yeah you got to put
it back in the bag and curry up and
during the truck yeah but maybe she's
just razzing around with her bud yeah
yeah like you go like that with the
Dixon to be friends but you were saying
like it was just really shocking and
traumatizing seeing the way these human
remains were being held
oh yeah [ __ ] gross it's like a zombie
movie
it's a bunch of body parts everywhere
especially like the wrong parts sewn
together that's freaking weird watch
your back Jen gets nobs kids this poor
son of a [ __ ] is back does he weigh
anything
you know what you're making it funny I'm
like how the [ __ ] do you make that funny
you're making it vital I know I mean
that's the law enforcement that I see in
movies yeah yeah they're like they do a
drug busts and then they start [ __ ]
around with everything so that
yeah you always [ __ ] crazy when I
worked at the hospital one of the there
was this one patient they had a whole
leg amputated and then like the surgical
tech when he was coming into our
department to bring in the used
instruments for us to reprocess them he
showed me the leg
cuz he was on the way to the incinerator
and I was like what did he walk in with
it next to his other legs cuz I got a
dick to ya know I was on the cart with
this sod like perfectly even like that
I didn't examine it he just like flipped
over the sheet cuz they put a sheet over
it cuz everything's [ __ ] bloody and
easy and they had to walk down hallways
so to put a sheet over it and so he just
went like hey look and they showed me
the leg I was like whoa damn that's
great people working here get so
desensitized that they could start
[ __ ] around like that all day long oh
yeah that's why she was laughing when he
showed me the [ __ ] leg I don't like
damn that's great what's he doing with
it was he jail I don't know he just he
just gave me a peek it wasn't like
actually messing with it I see he didn't
mess with it where it was like nah
that's too crazy we got so when they
raided this place they couldn't destroy
the remains because as part of the
investigation they took them to these
mortuaries to try to store them but
these mortuaries didn't have the proper
kind of freezer so then they started
decomposing Oh gross yeah so then they
were like [ __ ] I don't I mean how do you
get rid of 10 tonnes
so the family members that requested the
remains of their loved ones
they worry cancel their orders Oh what
if what if I came here not this they
said you wait too long you just keep it
like I heard kind of wet and I could
leaking in the bags you just pointed you
get your yeah your family member back
and it's just a tow you're like a
[ __ ] foot you're like what the [ __ ]
do you mean they don't give him the
actual body parts they cremate the but
the remains that I give them remains -
yeah wouldn't the cremation be like
infected if the body parts are like
infected like if they have some sort of
like disease or something right like I
know I was it like dissolve weird icily
and kind of chemical into it yeah well
if it burned it probably burns it away
I'm hoping right but I understand
one that because cremation is expensive
yes yeah my stepfather's cremated how
much was it remember I thought that she
was cheap mm-hmm it was a lot of money
yeah yeah that's a lot of gas I
understand why people would be
interested in like signing up for this
you know what I mean because they're
like okay we say money but that's so
[ __ ] up I know started getting sued or
oh yeah it's like this full-on
investigation thing going on like they
got shut down
I wonder who was the mastermind who
decided let's make money off a body part
FBI is involved here and that's huge do
you guys want to be there to cream in I
think cremated surprised me do you have
a special request for your ashes depart
nope I want mine to be dispersed all
over
Disneyland's like Main Street USA I do
yeah just [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz I don't
even like it shut up my ex wonder did I
just like that California Adventure
whatever that rollercoaster one has oh
wow yeah it was [ __ ]
[Music]